the town of dambulla is home to the  largest and best-preserved cave complex  in sri lanka  [Music]  while there are more than 80 documented  caves in the half-acre surrounding  dambulla there are five major caves that  draw the most visitors because each of  these caves contains a sprawling temple  a reoccurring image throughout the  complex is Buddha he can be found in  golden statue form measuring nearly 100  feet long the cave of Kings contains  over 55 different statues with the  largest one measuring 50 feet tall in  another cave there is a ceiling with  over 1500 paintings of Buddha on it in  addition to the frequent presence of  Buddhas there are also statues and  depictions of Sri Lankan kings and other  gods and deities throughout the cave  temples have existed for over 22  centuries and in recent years have  undergone conservation efforts to ensure  they are around for many centuries to  come  [Music]  you